Cada cuatro segundos,
a una persona se le diagnostica
la enfermedad de Alzheimer.
Es la causa más común de demencia,
ya que afecta a más de
40 millones de personas en todo el mundo
y los investigadores aún no
le han encontrado cura.
El Dr. Alois Alzheimer,
un psiquiatra alemán,
describió los síntomas
por primera vez en 1901
cuando se percató de que
una paciente de un hospital
tenía ciertos problemas,
que incluían dificultad para dormir,
problemas de memoria,
cambios de humor drásticos
y una confusión creciente.
Cuando la paciente falleció,
Alzheimer pudo realizar la autopsia
y comprobar su idea de que quizá
sus síntomas se debían a irregularidades
en la estructura cerebral.
Lo que descubrió
bajo el microscopio
fueron diferencias visibles
en el tejido cerebral
bajo la forma de proteínas
mal plegadas
llamadas placas seniles
y ovillos neurofibrilares.
Esas placas y ovillos actúan juntos
para destruir la estructura del cerebro.
Las placas aparecen
cuando otra proteína
de la membrana grasa
que rodea las células nerviosas
es separada por
una enzima concreta
lo que da lugar a
proteínas beta-amiloides,
que son pegajosas y tienen a
agruparse.
Estos depósitos son
los que forman
lo que conocemos
como placas seniles.
Estos depósitos
bloquean las señales
y por tanto, la comunicación
entre células y también desencadenan
reacciones autoinmunes que destruyen
las células nerviosas dañadas.
En el mal de Alzheimer,
los ovillos neurofibrilares
se forman a partir de una
proteína conocida como tau.
Las neuronas del cerebro están
formadas por una red de ramificaciones
que actúa como una autopista
para las moléculas de los alimentos
entre otras cosas.
Normalmente, la proteína tau
se encarga de que estas ramificaciones
estén rectas para
permitir que las moléculas
circulen libremente.
Sin embargo, con el Alzheimer
la proteína queda reducida
a hebras u ovillos,
que causan la destrucción
de las ramificaciones
e impiden que los nutrientes
lleguen a las células nerviosas
y esto provoca su muerte.
La unión destructiva de
las placas y los ovillos
comienza en una zona conocida
como el hipocampo,
que es la responsable
de formar los recuerdos.
Por ello, la pérdida de
memoria a corto plazo
es habitualmente el primer
síntoma de Alzheimer.
Las proteínas invaden
progresivamente
otras partes del cerebro,
lo que crea cambios
particulares que indican
los distintos estadios
de la enfermedad.
En la parte delantera
del cerebro,
las proteínas destruyen la habilidad
de procesar pensamientos lógicos.
Después, se mueven a la zona
que controla las emociones,
lo que provoca cambios
de humor erráticos.
En la parte superior del cerebro,
causan paranoia y alucinaciones
y cuando llegan a la parte
trasera del cerebro,
las placas y los ovillos
actúan juntos
para borrar los recuerdos
más profundos de la mente.
Finalmente, el centro
de control que dirige
el ritmo cardiaco y la respiración
sucumben también
y provocan la muerte.
La naturaleza inmensamente
destructiva de esta enfermedad
ha motivado a muchos investigadores
a buscar una cura
pero actualmente se centran
en reducir su avance.
Un tratamiento temporal
ayuda a reducir la destrucción
de acetilcolina,
un importante neurotransmisor
del cerebro
que disminuye en
los pacientes de Alzheimer,
debido a la muerte de las células
nerviosas que la producen.
Otra posible solución
es una vacuna
que enseña al sistema
inmunológico a atacar
a las placas de beta-amiloides
antes de que formen depósitos.
Sin embargo, aún tenemos
que encontrar una cura real.
La enfermedad de
Alzheimer se descubrió
hace más de un siglo
y todavía no se comprende del todo.
Quizá un día entendamos
los mecanismos exactos que
se desarrollan detrás de esta amenaza
y hallaremos una solución.